31 year old robert stock has made one
start in his major league career it was
against the mets at city field in a cubs
uniform earlier this year tonight he
makes his mets debut
maria drives one out to left this one
will stay in the ballpark dom smith
reels it in for the first down and
christian yellett steps in for milwaukee
and way inside so yelich does indeed
draw a one-out walk so the brewer's
first base runner against stock willie
adams will be the hitter swing and a
miss and he gets adamus with the slider
now that's his first strikeout as a met
two down and it'll bring up rowdy teles
the recently acquired first baseman
and rips one in the right field the base
hit and yelich will walk into second
base so first and second for milwaukee
and tolez's first brewer hit swinging a
bouncing ball to the shortstop hole
backhanded by lindor fires to second for
the force play side retired anderson
left started on june 21st he left in the
second inning he jammed his knee
and had to be removed gave up three runs
and those inning in the third
swing at the first pitch little roller
and vr is out for a quick out for brett
anderson
this one to short adamus
and there's two down well smith
went over three and was hit by a pitch
in the opener and that ended dom seven
game hitting streak the 2-2 line towards
right that's a base hit for smith who
continues to rank against left-handed
pitching played in by the right fielder
taylor and dom smith aboard with a two
out single and that will give pete
alonso a chance now to bat against the
lefty brett anderson lonzo hits one in
the air to right
a couple of steps towards the line
tyrone taylor he's there makes the catch
in the inning is over after one inning
brewers nothing mets nothing second walk
issued by stock there's manny pina then
a long stretch for manny pina one hit in
his last 42 at bats
and this one hit well right center field
all the way back and gone
perfect timing for manny pina his fifth
home run of the year ends a long drought
for him and gives milwaukee the early
lead
nothing better than that you're first at
bat you get a home run to give your team
a lead and boy he needed that in the
worst way so second time through the
order now for robert stock swinging a
liner in the left base hit for luis
urias he had two hits in the opener now
he's got another knock and it will bring
up christian yelich
on the outside corner strike three call
got him with a slider so for stock his
third strikeout but the brewers take the
lead in the second they scored two runs
james mccann will lead off in the home
second against the lefty brett anderson
and mccann gets a change up and bounces
it slowly ria's double clutches and lost
the play teles dropped it anyway and
mccann is safe at first well it was
going to be a routine play until uria's
have to reach in for it a second time
here's conforto conforto ground ball
double play ball peterson second one
adamus double play that erases
whatever it was a hit or an error
on that great double play term by
peterson
and williams went out nobody on third
inning it's two-nothing milwaukee as
rowdy teles bats live ball tour at the
left field line dom hoping for a play
near the side wall reaching in and he
got it oh wow
dom smith timing is jump perfectly
reaching into the crowd
terrific play by dom dom's starting to
have some highlight reels get a little
boost from the padding yeah look how he
sits on the top turnbuckle there but
it's nothing fourth inning milwaukee
leads the mets two to nothing jace
peterson will lead off
and peterson rips another base hit into
right field
boy he is just continuing to swing a
really good back good eye at the plate
swinging the bouncer left side vr grabs
it throws to second base one marasa
turns it to first two double play off
the bat of the slow-moving manny pina
5-4-3 around the horn swinging a missed
strike three stock with a fastball at 95
that he blows by jackie bradley juniors
second time through the order for
anderson is alive just two hits over the
first three innings line toward the
middle of base it for lindor and the
mets of the leadoff man on to the fourth
and there's one away now for pete alonso
no one to alonso could be two ground
ball to shore to dallas to second for
one on to first in time
and the brewers turn two and get
anderson through the inning drew smith
takes over in the top of the fifth
inning and avi garcia will bat for the
pitcher brett anderson so his day will
be done as well after four innings
and a fast ball gets garcia
and drew smith fans the first man to
face him
three pitches and drew smith takes care
of luis arias here's adamus to lead off
the sixth inning drew smith stays in the
game for second inning of work as this
one is hit hard left field and out of
here a home run
for william thomas
is 14th on the season ninth is a
milwaukee brewer and it's three-nothing
milwaukee he was having a difficult time
with that slider tonight look how short
and compact this swing is right here
nice and level ball jumps off his back
as soon as he make contact
he knew that was a homer
so the grill is with four home runs in
the double header two of them in game
two brad boxberger now comes in from the
bullpen to take over brandon nimmo is
going to bat in place of peraza and he
takes the walk
another tremendous flight appearance for
brandon nemo a nine pitch walk to start
the mets in the bottom of the sixth all
four to mcneil a beautiful at bat by
jeff back to back walks to nimmo and
mcneil has pinch hitters to set the
table in the bottom of the six rio
coming outside ball four foxburger
didn't come close
and now on three straight walks the mets
of the tying runs on base with nobody
out francisco lindor represents the
go-ahead run two balls two strikes on
lindor
and cole strike three on the outer edge
a nice pitch for boxberger to finally
get this first out best pitch in the
inning right there right on the outside
corner now dominic smith will bat one
two on the way
swing and a miss and another strikeout
for foxberger two down
a borderline strike up borderline away
and he had a very defensive swing at it
not out of the woods yet alonso has
flied out and bounced into a double play
strzok came out swinging a high fastball
and alonso went after it brad boxberger
after walking the bases loaded comes
back and strikes out lindor
smith and alonso
what a zero put up by brad boxberger
with bradley at second marius one for
three in the nightcap of this
doubleheader the pitch swinging a fly
ball deep left palar back gone
more insurance for the brewers it's five
nothing is luis urias it's his second
home run of the day his 12th of the
season
brewers are up a nickel boy did he put a
charge into that one a dozen home runs
for luis urias as we head to the bottom
of the seventh inning of game two hunter
strickland on to try and finish this one
out for the brewers here's the 2-2
and this one lifted into the air to
right field
and taylor has it for the first out the
2-0 conforto taps one first base side
that is a fair ball right near the back
teles picks it up steps on the bag from
number two that's down to their final
out drilling five to nothing it's one
more strike
there it is
and the brewers have done it here
winning the night cap by a final of five
to nothing